Prof: All right we have
here forth flown at a relatively
high altitude with the likes of
Adam Smith, Carl Marx,
Joseph Schumpeter,
F.A.
Hayek, and today and continuing
from here to the mid-term,
we're going to deal with real
businesses.
And it is our considerable
privilege to have with us Sharon
Oster,
who is a Harvard PhD in
Economics, is widely thought to
be the wisest owl on the
management of non-profit
organizations anywhere in the
world,
and is the Frederick Wolf
Professor of Entrepreneurship at
the School of Management,
and is, in addition to that,
a dean of that school.
So please help me welcome
Sharon Oster.
Sharon Oster:
Thank you all.
In my youth I taught at Yale
College and I taught generations
of undergrads intermediate
micro,
so it's nice to be back amongst
you,
teaching something a little bit
about economics.
I hope Doug warned you,
but I'm going to treat it like
a business school class,
which means I'm going to cold
call on you,
and people in the back should
know that I especially like
calling on the people in the
back because they tend to doze
otherwise,
so you might want to change
your seat.
So let's think about this case
a little bit.
So imagine yourself,
you're one of the three
entrepreneurs Ferrari,
Gold, and Dillon.
The world is your oyster in
some sense.
Here you are,
you've founded this firm,
you've got a product that's
this kit that can be used in
heart surgery,
big market, there's a million
people who need heart disease--
who need some kind of heart
surgery every year;
growing market,
we're all getting fatter,
we're getting older,
we're getting weaker,
we're getting less healthy,
you might think that's a
problem for President Obama and
the healthcare but it's an
opportunity for our
entrepreneurs.
This is a--even in the U.S.
they could imagine a billion
dollar market in this business,
not to mention the rest of the
world,
where people are also
overeating and getting less and
less healthy over time.
Yet when the case opens,
they seem like they have some
worries on their mind.
So if you were one of those
individuals, guys in this case,
what are you thinking about?
Student:  Marketing.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so what do you mean
by marketing?
What's the issue?
Student: Well,
the issue is you have this
product,
which could potentially be made
into a lot of money and help out
consumers,
but you have to work through
physicians,
since they're the ones who were
actually using this device,
and for them to use the device,
they need training.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so one set of
questions we're going to have
are a set of questions about the
buyer.
There are going to be a lot of
questions about the buyer but
let's just get that up there as
one set of things we're worried
about.
What are you worried about?
Student:  I guess I'd be
worried about the
competitiveness of my product to
make sure that it can actually
compete on the market.
Sharon Oster:  Good.
So you know at the moment--let
her have it,
she's doing okay--so at the
moment I only have one
competitor,
so what would we call that if
we were in economics class?
Student:  A duopoly.
Sharon Oster:
A duopoly okay.
Now one of the things we know
about duopolies,
if they're any kind of sensible
duopolies they're probably doing
pretty well.
This duopolist,
my competitor,
what's his price point look
like?
Student:  Price point?
Sharon Oster:
Yeah so he--I'm charging
$1,000 for my thing,
what's he charging?
Anybody remember the number?
Student:  $5,000.
Sharon Oster:
$5,000--they're good they
know the numbers..
Prof: I told you they
were good.
Sharon Oster:
So I'm thinking to myself
you're worried about the
competition,
but I got one competitor and
he's charging five times my
price,
that makes me look like I'm
pretty good.
Is there something else you're
worried about?
Student:  Well it's not
just that one competitor,
but its other techniques also.
Sharon Oster:  Good.
Okay, so one thing I'm worried
about right now is my existing
competitor,
but Schumpeter doesn't tell me
that I should only worry about a
static competition,
does he?
What is Schumpeter's model
about what's happening with
competition?
Student:  Creative
destruction to the other firms
that went to market and less
successful firms were forced out
of the market.
Sharon Oster:
So a thing that I have to
worry about is not just the
extant competitor's Heartport,
but I better think a little bit
about who else is coming,
so I'm going to be thinking a
little bit about what Michael
Porter,
who you also looked at I guess,
is new entry and how do I
understand new entry?
Then if I think about the flip
side of Schumpeter not only am I
worried about some new guys
coming in and destroying me,
but as I come in I'm of course
competing against some existing
players.
I need to think a little bit
existing players and the way in
which they are attacking this
market.
One of the things you're going
to observe about almost every
new product as it enters the
market,
even if it thinks of itself as
a new product it has existing
competitors.
Many of you may have Kindles,
if you look at Kindles the
Kindle is obviously also worried
about what's happening with the
Sony Reader and all the new
things that look like a Kindle,
but really from the point of
Kindle's--
from Kindle's point of view its
real job at the moment is
converting all those people who
are buying hard covered books.
It is thinking a little bit
about conversion of consumers
from the way in which they are
currently used to solving a
problem to your new way of
solving a problem,
so we're going to have to think
here in competition not only
about the guys that are doing it
our way,
but the existing players.
And we're going to have to
think about these things in the
context of a set of issues
involving the customers,
how I connect to the customers,
how I deliver to whoever these
customers are,
and we'll have to think about
that,
and a set of different products
for the needs of our people.
I'm going to stay with those
two things for awhile and then
Doug will help me pull down the
slides to get to some other
questions in the end,
but this is going to take care
of us for a little while.
Let's stick with the
competition part of it first.
Before I came along,
kind of how is it that people
got their heart problem solved?
Guy in the back with the pink
shirt in the last row.
Student:  Either bypass
surgery or the balloon
procedure.
Sharon Oster:
Good and do you have a
vague idea about of these one
million patients,
about how they divide up?
Student:  I don't know.
Sharon Oster:
Anybody else remember
about the numbers?
They're not perfect;
so the CABG is about 350,000
and the angioplasty--
Prof: There is some
hands up; we got to get them to
where she can see.
Sharon Oster:
Oh, if it's a number like
that you can just yell.
You don't even have to raise
your hand.
We're a much more casual group
than that in business school.
I've got two different ways of
doing it;
let's stick with you,
do you got the mic handy?
Good.
Tell me a little bit about my
organization,
CardioThoracics,
competing against competitors
in each of those two markets.
Student:  In the first
model of cardiothoracic systems,
it only allowed doctors to do
surgery on one or two blood
vessels,
which would have replaced,
I believe,
the market for the balloon
procedure,
angioplasty.
Whereas, for the bypass
surgery, it was usually,
in that case,
because they were creating more
trauma,
they would usually try to
address as many vessels as
possible.
Sharon Oster:
Okay so one of the things
about this particular product is
in its infancy it could only do
one or two vessels at a time,
and that limited it really
pretty much to this side of the
picture,
because most of what we were
doing--
this side of the picture
involved, as you indicated,
a little more drastic cutting,
and typically then more
treatment of multiple vessels.
Generation 1 sort of focused on
this part of the market.
Now, as you indicated,
the technological trajectory
was to more and more vessels,
so we're going to spend a
little bit of money if we're
this firm and we're going to
move to not only solving those
problems but solving those
problems.
Does that change come without a
cost?
As I move from Generation 1 to
Generation 2,
to Generation 3,
I get more and more vessels,
do I lose anything?
Student:  You have to
pay for--
you have to invest in the
product, you have to train and
retrain doctors,
you have to market it over and
over again.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so one set of
questions is as I'm doing
anything technological,
I'm going to have to invest
real cash in this.
I'm going to have to think a
little bit about that,
but is there anything else I
lose as I move from one
generation to another?
Yeah.
Student:  Well it's
harder because the whole point
is to have a beating heart so it
could be longer,
so it's two different
>
Sharon Oster:
Okay, well that's true.
It's harder to do more vessels
because I've got more things I'm
trying to do as its beating,
but there's something else I'm
doing as I move from Generation
1 onward.
Yeah.
Student:
>
Sharon Oster:
Great, so if you think
about this product in the
beginning, it had two kind of
technological features.
One was it dealt with the
bleeding heart--
beating heart,
not bleeding heart--and the
second one it had a smaller cut,
so you didn't want to cut all
the way through people,
you actually wanted to have a
little bitty hole,
so small incision,
and it turned out that the
beating heart eliminated some of
the neurological problems,
and the small incision made
people recover a little bit
faster.
So they were different elements
of the product that we liked.
When we moved from the kind of
only a couple vessels to many
vessels,
we're giving up on some of the
functionality associated with
the product by cutting up
patients a little bit more and
that's another feature that
Schumpeter and others have
talked about,
including Clay Christensen,
who talks about disruptive
innovation that when you make a
product change it is often the
case that you don't just
improve,
improve, improve, improve.
You give up things;
there are tradeoffs that you're
making.
And the tradeoffs are not just
to cost you more money and you
get more functionality,
but sometimes you actually push
along one dimension and you're
drawing back actually in what--
in the qualities of another
dimension.
In this situation why put the
money in and give up the small
incision piece just to enable
yourself to move into this piece
of the market?
After all the one or two
vessels market is the biggest
chunk of the market and it's
pretty darn big,
I'm just a little guy,
why don't I manage as I am
focusing on that part of the
market?
Why is it I have to go--why is
it I decide to transform myself?
Here in the back,
the woman in the corner?
Student:  Because you
have
to-->
Sharon Oster:
You have to say that
louder for me or slower,
so I got a piece of it but I
didn't get it all,
so start again.
Student:  You need to
think about the preferences of
your consumers,
the doctor that are going to be
adopting your technology,
you need a larger incision so
they can see the heart that
they're working on.
And so it's not just about
moving from a couple vessels to
many, it's about catering to
their preferences.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so one of the things
I'm going to be thinking about
here as I'm thinking about
technologically what to do to my
product,
is that when I change what I
can do technologically,
I am picking a different set of
markets that I'm trying to
compete against.
And these markets are going to
look very different in terms of
the kind of buyer issues and the
complimentor,
and we'll talk about what I
mean by that in a minute,
for each of these two parts of
the market.
I am choosing my competition in
some sense by choosing my
technology.
I'm choosing to go against here
a set of--who's doing these CABG
things?
These are surgeons,
so these are surgeons,
they're cutting people up.
Who's doing the angioplasty?
What looks different about that?
Student:  Cardiologists.
Sharon Oster:
These are cardiologists;
they're being done in a
different kind of an office,
much less invasive procedure,
very different features
associated with these two parts
of the market.
And my ability,
given what I am,
to compete in each of these two
markets is going to vary much,
so the technological trajectory
is influenced by the economics
and the competitive piece of the
story.
That you are not just imagining
yourself, a bunch of scientists
in a lab, just trying to make it
better, better,
better, better.
You've got a set of managers on
top who are saying,
"You know what,
we need to have an improvement
on this dimension,
because otherwise we're never
going to be anyplace in this
marketplace."
A decision was made,
and we're going to turn to
figuring out why this decision
was made,
that it was going to be
important to be in this part of
the market and not just this
part of the market to get myself
some more functionality with
multi vessels.
Okay, so to think about why I
needed to go that way I want to
switch over a little bit to this
piece--
we're going to come back to
this part in a minute as well.
I want to think a little bit
about the buyer issues.
The woman in the back said if I
want to do something about
knowing my technology,
I've got to figure out what
does the consumer want.
Is that the relevant decision
maker in this case?
I'll put that here,
I've got a patient,
and I'll call that patient the
consumer.
When people go and they're
trying to have some heart
procedure do they just--
there's something the matter
with your heart,
they just come up to you and
say to you,
"How do you want me to do
that?
How do you think--what
procedure do you think I should
use?"
So who else is a decision maker
in this situation?
Yeah.
Student:  The doctor is
one of the major decision makers
in this process because it's
talking about the whole concept
of having the doctor needing to
be trained, and using their
materials.
Sharon Oster:
In fact,
there are actually three
different doctors you might
think play a role in this
situation.
The one you mentioned is a
surgeon.
Student:  There's also
the referring doctors.
Sharon Oster:
Good, so there's your
basic GP or whatever it is you
have,
some guy you go,
you put on--I've got a pain in
my chest,
he says, "You better do
something about that,"
and then there is a
interventional cardiologist,
who does this piece of the
business.
You--some doctor says,
"Go see somebody,"
and typically he actually says,
"Go see this guy,"
and this guy figures out can he
help you or can she help you,
and if not they send you to a
surgeon.
You've got interveners or
decision makers all along the
doctor element.
Is there anybody else you think
that, if I'm the inventors of
this little kit,
is there anyone else I need to
talk too, need to think about?
Yeah.
Student:  Insurance.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, insurance companies.
So it turns out,
one of the curiosities about
healthcare,
and it's the one that's
bedeviling the Obama team now in
terms of figuring things out,
is we have this breakage of the
link between people who make
decisions about things and the
people who pay for it.
In this situation,
the patients have some stake in
the procedure,
the doctors have a lot to say,
but the poor insurance
companies,
and/or the government are
actually doing a lot of the
paying for it.
Needless to say in that kind of
arrangement, eventually the
insurance company starts having
an opinion too and making its
opinion felt.
If you are in the business of
medical devices or pharma,
in any way at all,
you're going to be thinking a
little bit about how is the
insurance company going to
reimburse for this kind of a
thing?
Is there anybody else that has
an opinion about this?
Yeah.
Student:  Hospitals.
Sharon Oster: Hospitals.
Why do the hospitals care?
Student:  I mean,
just from the insurance
standpoint, and whether or not
they want these technologies to
be used at their hospital.
Sharon Oster:  So--good.
So hospitals actually turn out
to have an interesting set of
issues about this particular
thing.
Hospitals, to the extent that
they are reimbursed by
insurance,
and that's going to be true for
most of the patients in this
environment,
are reimbursed on what's known
as a capitated basis,
which means an insurance
company says to you,
"If you're treating
somebody who has a particular
heart problem,
I'm going to give you a fixed
amount for it."
That's quite a difference from
the way we used to--
insurance used to pay,
which was, "You treated
somebody,
let me see what your bills are,
I'm going to pay you."
In an attempt to get some kind
of efficiency they actually went
to a system,
sometimes called DRGs,
in which they said,
"For an average,
more or less healthy guy who
has this problem,
I'm going to pay you X to treat
him."
If I'm going to pay--if that's
the way I have my hospital
reimbursement happen,
how does the hospital feel
about my particular device?
What do you think?
Student:  Not great,
probably.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so one thing it
doesn't like is its just costing
them money, so it's kind of just
taking it off the top.
Might there be anything about
it they would like?
Yeah, in the back.
Student:  The device
improves patient recovery time
and reduces mortality,
because that's one of the
things I wanted to try to
quantify.
Sharon Oster:
Yeah, and there could be
other people who care about the
mortality in particular,
but the first thing you said
was about recovery time.
Why might the hospital be
especially interested in that?
Yeah.
Student:  Well because I
know for most of the time it--
the procedure is capitated for
payment,
and a lot of times recovery
time is also going to fall under
that payment,
and the longer you recover
you're not going to get any more
money for that,
so if you have quicker
recoveries you're
>
Sharon Oster:
So it's actually going to
vary for different hospitals
depending on the contract that
they're going to get.
So for some hospitals I just
give you a fee,
and that would mean if I
get--if this procedure gets you
out of your bed and to home
faster,
that's a benefit for the
hospital because they basically
only have to keep you in three
days,
not seven, I save some money.
On the other hand,
what does this device do to the
amount of time I need to use as
an operating surgeon?
Student:
>
Sharon Oster:
Probably increases it.
And from the point of view of
hospitals, most hospitals are
more constrained in operating
room time than they are in
hospital bed time.
Again, it's going to depend a
little bit on the hospital how
they feel about this,
and a little bit on how much
we've pushed down in terms of
the insurance,
but the hospital is definitely
going to have some kind of say.
Now notice something about
these groups,
they all have opinions,
they all have a role to play in
the kind of decision that's
going to affect my ability to
compete in these parts of the
market.
Do they all have the same kinds
of preferences?
Guy in the orange.
Student:
>
Sharon Oster:
Talk to me a little bit
about how each of these players,
or a couple of these players,
might feel about the idea of
introducing this kit that
enables people to operate on
your heart.
Student:  I mean it's
going to have a different
response from each one of the
buyers.
Potentially,
doctors can make more money off
of it,
it's just if it's less
technologically inclined for
example,
so I mean their previous
systems could have made them a
lot more money,
whereas patients could actually
benefit if this system actually
lowered costs,
so each one of the buyers is
going to have different
responses towards costs.
Sharon Oster:
Okay that's a little
vague.
Let's sharpen it up.
You can sharpen it up for us.
It's not wrong,
it's just a little vague.
Student:  Okay so like
sharpening things up.
In terms of the patient and
consumer,
I think what he was trying to
say, was that with these new
technologies it'll require
greater training that the doctor
may or may not be able to afford
or go through.
But it might also benefit a
patient because the technology
would be less invasive,
or something like that.
But there's a higher risk
involved because there weren't
as many testing's that--
as were mentioned before,
so that could offset the
patient preference of going
under the knife of something
that isn't that tested.
Sharon Oster:  Good.
Okay, so a couple of issues
here.
One is there's certainly a
question about the doctor
training,
and one of the things that's
going to keep me awake as an
entrepreneur is thinking a
little bit about the doctor
training,
which we are going to get to in
a couple of minutes.
Certainly the doctors are going
to be right away at me and
saying,
"Okay, how am I going to
get to learn that kind of
thing?"
You can already begin to see
it's not going to be the kind of
thing I'm going to have a course
that I charge for.
It is going to be--I'm going to
have to figure out some way to
incentivize these guys to come
to my particular class and learn
something about it,
and we'll talk about what that
is.
The other thing I heard you say
was something about risk.
Let's think about the risk
issues for the surgeon versus
the patient and how they weight
those things.
Now in theory if we're doing
surgery, what's the medical
benefit of this particular
product?
The guy in the red in the back.
Student:  I think it
reduces the mortality rate of
patients.
Sharon Oster:
Okay so one thing it may
do is reduce mortality rate,
although it's a little bit
tricky in the beginning,
because we don't know how good
the doctors are going to be.
The initial real kind of
consumer sale piece of this,
was less on the mortality and
more on what?
Yeah.
Student:  The recovery
rate is whatever they can get
out of >
Sharon Oster:
Okay so some of it is I
can reduce your recovery rate.
If we think about that,
does the doctor care a lot
about how fast you get back to
work?
Student:  No,
that's the--well I mean--yes I
guess that's when it's your
patient.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so one of the things
we might think about,
the recovery angle is that the
patient is going to care more
than the doctor.
So that's going to be an
element, recovery time,
in which we've got an asymmetry
in terms of how much the people
value these things.
What's another element?
Yeah.
Student:  The trauma.
Sharon Oster:
The trauma.
Student:  The sudden
neurological complications that
develop after surgery.
Sharon Oster:
Yeah, so another thing
about this surgery is you have
to be on a heart-lung machine
and that actually has
neurological problems
potentially associated with it.
So we've got something that's
actually potentially going to
reduce some of our neurological
problems.
It turns out for various
studies people have done who
study doctors and medical care
kinds of things,
if you thought about the
tradeoff to a patient and asked
the question,
"How much incremental risk
of death would you be willing to
face to avoid the kind of very
serious neurological damage?
The answer to that question is
very different for patients then
it is to doctors.
From the doctors point of view
the danger of having someone die
on the table is enormous
relative to any other problem.
From the patients point of view
there are times in which they
are willing to tradeoff and say,
"There are some conditions
that I could have that,
frankly, I would just as soon
take a chance of dying."
That's been actually a very
complicated set of issues for
doctor/patient relationships
across a whole range of
different operative and surgical
procedures.
It says to me in this
situation, where we are talking
about heart recovery kinds of
issues,
those tradeoffs are going to
become potentially very large.
When we have a risk of death
that's going to be larger for
the doctor,
and the risk of damage is going
to be conversely more important
from the patient's point of
view.
Now let's think a little bit
about these different players
and look at these two parts of
the market.
Because we started this by
saying that these guys did a
whole bunch of technological
things to try to move into this
part of the market,
as opposed to staying in this
rather larger part of the
market.
As we think about these being
the deciders among the things,
why is it technologically
imperative to get out of this
market and into this market?
Yeah.
Student:  Cardiologists
would be the ones who refer you
to surgery,
and if they are the ones who
perform the procedure,
they then benefit being able to
perform the procedure
themselves,
so they have a quasi-monopoly
over the market in some sense.
Sharon Oster:
So some people call this
the "gatekeeper
problem."
It turns out in this particular
market I've got a gatekeeper
problem,
which is my big competition,
are the ones that are going to
basically handle this
themselves,
and their tendency to then say,
"You know,
you've got two vessels,
I could deal with it,
but I think you'd be better off
going here now that we have a
kit," is going to be much
reduced.
So I've got a problem that my
competitor is a gatekeeper for
me.
There's another problem also in
this--attacking this part of the
market.
Let's think about it from the
point of view of the patient.
How does the patient,
who has just one or two vessels
damaged, feel about these two
procedures?
Yeah.
Student:  Angioplasty is
already quite non-intrusive,
so there isn't a huge benefit
gained by trying to--the new,
rather untested method.
Sharon Oster:
If you think about what
this is--
I actually did some work for
Boston Scientific in this market
as an economist and they--
even though I was only an
economist they actually wanted
me to watch one of these
procedures for reasons that
completely escape me.
If you watch one of these
things it's--the patient is
awake the whole time.
There is--basically what they
do is,
there's a little blockage in
one of your arteries,
they put a thing that looks
sort of this,
but a little smaller up your
leg, they weave it up until it
gets to the right part in which
there's a blockage,
they have a balloon at the end
of it,
they have a little machine that
blows up the balloon,
the balloon just presses
against the wall of the artery,
all the junk that was clogging
it up goes whish and kind of
floats away,
we hope to wherever nirvana is,
and then they take it out and
off you go.
It's very non-invasive,
that's very appealing to the
consumer, I've got a gatekeeper
here who's a cardiologist.
What would the insurance
company rather have me do?
Oh, this is way cheaper.
These angioplasty things are
way cheaper than anything in the
CABG side.
So anyone that's an insurer is
going to be thinking,
"You've only got one or
two vessels,
go this way rather than trying
to do a less problematic version
of this."
From the point of view of
solving the needs of these
people, I can't stay in this
part of the business.
I don't have enough value add
to offer in that part of the
business.
I have got to go to the only
part of the business in which I
have potential value add,
which is this part of it,
and for that it says to me,
"Even though I'm going to
give up something in
functionality I'm going to need
to give that up in order to make
myself more attractive in that
part of the business."
Because from the point of view
of everything--pretty much
everything these guys care
about, this thing is dominated.
Now--we'll come to the little
more on the competition in a
minute.
Let me backtrack slightly from
that aggressive comment I just
made,
because there is one problem,
for those of you that read
carefully,
there is one problem that the
angioplasty has that would be
improved by me actually trying
to do this in a less invasive
way.
Yeah.
Student:  Well one of
the problems is that the plaque
often returns because the vessel
is trying to heal itself,
and it can be a bigger problem
and you don't have to do the
procedure then.
Sharon Oster:
Great.
So an issue that we have from
the point of view--
an issue that this competitor
has is something medically,
it's called restenosis,
so that I could have this done,
but I have to do it many times
and then you could think,
now what the patient is
thinking is,
"Do I want to have this
with the kit done once,
or do I want to have this done
every other year,
which sounds a little less
appealing than it sounded a
minute ago when I thought we
could just do it once and for
all."
Initially you might think,
"Well it looks like there
is some advantage I could build
on in my discussions with
patients and doctors,
and frankly even insurers and
hospitals,
that would make me an
attractive alternative to
this."
But if I was thinking in a
Schumpeterian way and going to
build my business around that,
what else would I want to be
thinking about in terms of that
strategy?
So a strategy that says,
"Okay,
I'm looking at what these guys
are like now and I'm thinking
about how I look relative to
them,
and there is something they
don't do very well,
and I'm going to just kind of
hammer in on what they don't do
well."
What's the potential worry that
I might have about that?
Yeah.
Student:  Well,
I think it's just the
gatekeeper problem that you were
saying.
All the people that do that not
that well are the people that
are going to recommend your
patients to the surgeons that
you are ultimately selling your
product to.
So it's really not going to
work out very well.
Sharon Oster:
Okay good,
so keep the mic.
So that tells me if I were
going to go that way,
what would I need to be doing?
Student:  You have to
expand so that interventionist
cardiologists can use the
product,
or eliminate the gatekeeper
problem in some way,
I guess.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so I've got to
figure out a way to get over the
gate.
What's a way to get over the
gate?
Student:  I have no idea.
Student:  Talking to
patients so that--you can target
the patients so that demand it
from their doctor,
from their cardiologist.
Sharon Oster:
Good.
So we could think a little bit
about what's been happening--
those of you that watch
television,
probably none of you
anymore--one of the things we've
seen in the healthcare area is
much more direct advertising to
patients.
Even for things that you would
think your doctor--
these are things your doctor is
going to prescribe for you or
make you do in one way or
another,
there is an attempt in a lot of
areas to avoid the gatekeeper by
going direct to the patients.
How easy is that to do in this
market as opposed to a market
like allergy relief?
Okay, if there's--there are
markets now for Claritin or one
of these drugs that is
prescription,
so the only way you can get it
is to go to your doctor,
but the line is,
"Go to your doctor and ask
them to prescribe this drug for
you."
Is it going to be easy for me
to have on television something
that says,
"Go to your doctor and
tell them you don't want an
angioplasty,
you want your CABG done with
the beating heart kit?"
So why are you all laughing?
What's ridiculous about this?
Student:  It's
information asymmetry.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, so (a) it's
complicated, information
asymmetry is exactly right.
You could think,
"Okay, I could go to my
doctor with that,
but what the hell do I know?
I mean, really,
I'm not going to trust my own
view of this even if the
television told me so,"
but there's actually another
just sort of business issue
which is,
there, in some sense,
aren't enough people watching
TV for whom that message is
relevant.
Even if I could really focus in
on TV and do it I'm going to
be--it's going to be a problem.
There are some possibilities
maybe on the way.
You could imagine a set of web
advertisements that when you're
clicking on something that says
what do I do about a heart
problem?
It clicks up to me,
"Talk to your doctor about
the beating Heartport kit."
So there are some technological
things directed at marketing
that actually allow us in
various markets to get away from
gatekeepers and go direct.
There's actually another
problem with building a lot on
this strategy.
As I think about building a
strategy to attack an existing
player, any of you have game
theory?
Any of you ever take game
Did--any of you economics
majors?
Okay, good I'm picking on you
because you should know this as
an econ major.
If you're thinking about
positioning yourself against an
existing competitor,
I'm looking at what this guy is
doing now,
what else should I be looking
at?
Student:  How he's going
to react to my reaction.
Sharon Oster:  Exactly.
I need to be thinking this
guy--what is he going to be
doing, sitting around,
kind of reaping in the profits?
He's going to be thinking about
here you came with this new
business, and you're attacking
me--by virtue of my restenosis,
what am I going to do?
Now I want to think a little
bit about, if I'm the designer
of this thing,
is who are these players?
Anyone have any sense of who
the guys are doing the
angioplasty business,
producing these balloon
catheters and so on?
Well they're big companies,
companies like some of you may
want to work for some day;
Boston Scientific,
Medtronic, Johnson &
Johnson.
What's true about these big
companies?
They spend a lot of money on
R&D because they make a lot
of money.
They have broad product lines,
they have big cash flows,
and they spend a lot on
R&D.
You, some little pip squeak
making Heartport,
are going to rack your whole
business on the idea that you
don't--
you can attack these guys by
saying they're going to have--
you're going back to the
hospital a lot,
you can be sure they know
that's an issue for their
company and they're throwing a
lot of money at it.
In fact, what we see in this
business is actually we get,
very shortly after this
position, a new drug eluding
stint that allows for less
restenosis,
that they have spent many,
many, many millions of dollars
on.
I think it is very dangerous to
stick with the two vessel thing
because you know these guys (a)
in the first place,
you don't have the value
proposition for consumers,
and (b) you've got very strong
competitors who have a lot of
money to throw at a particular
problem that they have.
Just a couple more things we
want to think about.
The training issues;
if I'm actually going to make
this work in this business I
have got what economists would
call a complement--
with an "e",
not an "i."
I've got to somehow--this kit
doesn't do it itself,
this kit is used by doctors,
surgeons;
so I've got to figure out a way
to train those guys.
In the case they talk about
some of the ways they try to
train these guys.
One is they offer them trips to
Hawaii.
What's the problem with the
trips to Hawaii to learn?
Student:  A lot of the
doctors are coming there just to
look at the actual product not
to learn how to use it.
It's like they've heard about
it, they're interested just to
learn more about it,
not actually apply it,
and it turned out that I think
actually only two people stayed
for the surgery on the pig to
see what actually happened.
Sharon Oster:
Good, and since you're an
econ major we'll test you a
little more on the econ.
There's a problem in economics
known as the selection problem,
so how does the selection
problem play into this?
What kind of doctors go to
Hawaii?
Student:  What kind of
doctors go to Hawaii?
Doctors that like beaches.
Sharon Oster:
Okay, they like beaches,
and when they go to Hawaii I'm
paying for their transport,
but what am I not covering?
What's the magic word--there
are only three magic--
Student: Opportunity
costs.
Sharon Oster:
Oh, thank you,
that's the magic word.
Student:  So I guess it
would, if we follow that logic,
it's doctors that go to Hawaii
instead of being paid heftily by
hospitals.
Sharon Oster:
You bet,
so a strategy that says,
"Come to Hawaii,"
attracts a bunch of doctors who
aren't doing many surgeries,
because they've got plenty of
time to come to Hawaii.
The people that I want to
attract are the people that are
doing a lot of surgeries because
they are an annuity,
a word for those of you that
are interested in finance.
Once I teach them,
every year they do more
surgeries, every year I don't
have to keep reteaching them
every year they do something.
Moreover, I want the guys who
are in teaching hospitals like
Yale because they're going to
teach all the guys behind them,
and I want them to be big
users, and that's why most of
the training for these kind of
things actually happens in the
hospital.
It doesn't happen in Hawaii.
Hawaii sounds great to somebody
who doesn't know anything about
doctors.
What you want to do is you want
to go where they are,
train them where they are,
where there's low opportunity
cost of learning as a way to
capturing.
Still it's going to be a tricky
piece to try to do it.
We have a situation in which it
looks like a good idea;
we've got big hurdles to go
over in terms of actually having
a value add that's meaningful.
Suppose I could,
suppose I did have something
that I convinced--
I got enough dotors to know how
to do it,
I got enough stories to
consumers and others that I got
around intervention
cardiologists--
there's a lot of ifs about
this--and I'm getting some
penetration of this thing.
Now what am I worried about?
Yeah.
Student:  Is insurance
going to cover it.
Sharon Oster:
Okay I could worry
about--is insurance going to
cover it?
But suppose I got that,
I've managed to convince those
insurance companies that this is
going to get people out of the
hospital faster;
this is going to be a good deal.
Here I am just starting to make
money.
What do we know when you're
just starting to make money?
What happens to you?
What kind of a science is
economics?
The dismal science;
why is it the dismal science?
Because the minute you start
making money what happens?
Student:  People enter
the market.
Sharon Oster:
People enter the market.
That's the glory of why prices
come down.
In this situation what kind of
a product do we have?
We have a little platform for a
beating heart.
When we convince the doctors to
adapt it,
we want it to have something
that was going to look pretty
generic,
because I wanted to give
doctors some sense of,
"You can learn how to make
this,
and I'm not going to hold you
up eventually."
The easier it is to copy,
however, the more problem I
have from new entry.
Even if I can crack this
problem by attracting the right
buyers,
solving the complimentary
problem, changing myself
technologically to hit the only
part of the market in which I
have a chance to compete,
I'm going to have a problem
that I'm going to have the risk
of new guys coming in.
The more attractive I make this
from a generic point of view in
the beginning of my market,
the more problem I'm going to
have protecting it in a later
part of my market.
That, in some sense,
is really the Schumpeterian
story that says to me the nature
of an innovation is coming in
against existing players with
something you hope will be a
better idea.
Then worrying in the end about
other people who are going to
imitate you,
until finally there are enough
of them until another newcomer
comes in with another disruptive
innovation that looks better
than what you had before.
I have to actually go teach my
MBAs and so your last five
minutes Mr. Rae is going to
complete for you.
Prof: As you can see
she's done that before.
Now the question the syllabus
poses for you is concerned with
social learning,
with whether the market and
companies like this one are
instruments by which society
learns through both success and
failure.
Does anybody see a learning
component to this?
Let's get a mic for somebody.
Let's go to purple shirt right
here.
What's the learning process
here?
Student:  Do you mean
the learning process for the
players in this particular case?
Prof: Well I mean
something more abstract and
bigger.
Is society smarter in any
important way toward the end of
this story than it was at the
beginning?
Student:  I suppose
it--I suppose it depends on
whether the new product ends up
being adapted,
because if it--I mean if it
ends up being sort of accepted,
because then in which case
we've had a technological
innovation that will maybe save
some lives,
reduce some recovery time,
but if the product never enters
the market--
I mean, I guess if there's this
pressure to innovate,
even if it doesn't enter the
market,
maybe the angioplasty guys will
be out there trying to compete
even though it's not really a
major competitor.
Prof: Okay so in actual
fact there's a learning story
with a yes answer and a learning
story with a no answer.
The learning story with the yes
answer is very obvious.
The learning answer with the
failure story is partly that we
know one bad idea so we don't
have to repeat it.
In addition,
it's part of a larger
incentivation process which
compels everyone to be thinking
about the next step beyond what
they already know how to do.
In the case for Monday,
which is its URL is posted on
class as V2;
we have the Polaroid Land
camera, invented by Edwin Land.
It is a less bloody story that
is a little like the one we just
did.
The difference is that it is
closer to the mass consumer and
is in that way a more typical
Schumpeter story about how
innovation in consumer products
disturbs an old equilibrium in
conventional photography and
then becomes a defender against
a new disruptive technology with
the emergence of digitization.
We'll see you on Monday.